[Music]
foreign
in Italy is becoming the illegal
immigration too many immigrants from for
example to protect the traditional
family a family composed by Mom ajad and
Sons for example how does she do that
not admitting the the
marriages between people from the same
the same gender
foreign
she's trying to
delete us and send a message that we are
the cause of we are the reason why Italy
doesn't have enough children we are the
reason why we have demographic problems
we are the reason why the family is not
holding strong and we are scared
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
been a hindrance or a help
it's been both she says certainly when I
entered politics my last name was a
springboard
[Music]
historical flame of the the old party
but if there was no connection with
fascism no no but why wouldn't they
change their symbol then no no no no no
no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
says there's nothing to worry about
but are you worried
yes very much
very very boring I think that she is
fascist